こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
皆さま、人間が生きている上で一番恥ずかしいことは何でしょうか
皆さん、人間が生きている上で一番恥ずかしいことは何でしょうか、そう
いや、悪いと言いたいわけではないです
生理現象なので仕方がないことは私も認識しております
そこはまぁよしとしましょう
よしとするのですがやはり道徳的に考えると非常に恥ずかしい思いをしてしまう
それが
そのおもらしの最大レベルに君臨するのが、そう
（今、それを経験しようとしている1人の後輩がいた）
というわけで今回なんとかまさきを僕の家に寝かせることに成功しました
今回は
もし後輩が先輩の家でおもらしをしてしまったらドッキリ
をやります
多分、ターゲットこのまま何もしなかったら漏らさないので
なんとかして私の手で
ターゲットがあたかも漏らしたような状況を作り出すことを今回考えてみました
用意するのはこちら
りんごジュースでございます
まぁこの透け感といい、中々の尿感が出ているのではないでしょうか
普通にりんごジュースですからね
あ～～
やっぱ最高だわ～
それはなぜかと言うとまず温度差があります
人間の体内から放出される液はおそらくなんですけども
多分、人間の体温と同じような温度になってると思います
温度差が激しすぎてバレてしまう可能性もあるし
尿とはほど遠い温度になっている
そういう観点を含めてこれを今から体温に近い温度まで上昇させます
体温と尿の温度差はほぼなし
もう、サッ！サッ！という感じで静かに浸透して
起きた瞬間
なぜか
股間周りが
黄色く濡れている。
純粋になんですけど
言い訳が気になります
ではいこう
*点火*
温度測ります
あっつ！あっつ！
ちょっと冷めるんで今熱いくらいでいいと思います
はい
完成でーす
というわけで完成したので
僕も一緒に今から寝ますまさきと。
♂♂
一緒に寝て良きタイミングでまさきの股間にこうやってちょっと垂らして
おもらししている状況を無理矢理作りこんで
完全犯罪を成功させます
♪♪♪
( ^)o(^ )
まさき：$！＄なにぃ？
まさき：なになになになにww
まさき：何？ｗ
まさき：なぁにこれw
まさき：何wかwけwらwれwたwのwこwれw
*偽起床*
はじめ：おはようまさき
はじめ：え、待って
はじめ：いや待って待って
まさき：違う違う違うw
はじめ：え、待って　完全に
はじめ：ちょっと待て待て待て
はじめ：いや待て待て
え？
はじめ：待って
はじめ：完全に
まさき：違う
まさき：ﾁｭｶﾞｳ
ほらほらうわっほら！
完　全　に　！
まさき：－－違う
まさき：違うw違うw違うw違うw
まさき：違う、絶対これ
まさき：りんごジュースの匂いwww